die gerne firma
der endstand
amica chips
anna loos war man bei der emsstadt
einzeller geht man der hersteller hama
step magath hat schon beim hinflug
gesehen fragt wohin ich bin hier auch
selbst zusammen mit luca und wir sind
von vodafone eingeladen worden wie man
unschwer erkennen kann hier mit
möglicherweise quip weil wir waren
gerade schon mal im wasser
beziehungsweise auf dem wasser also
zwischen dingen weil wir sind kurz
gefahren und wir binden so nass aber es
war richtig cool und jetzt müssen wir
erstmal was die haben allerdings keine
schuhe und was wir heute hier machen
werden wir schauen uns einfach ein
bisschen gucken was man hier so machen
kann die verschiedenen stände sonstwas
und so ein bisschen die stadt hier noch
alles wieder ganz gut
und herr sport los
ratlos da
doch statt
wir waren gerade einkaufen
luca hat eine hose gefunden das heißt
ich kann meine trockene andere hose bin
so glücklich und in den livestream rein
aber noch mal hierher schuh oder was mir
aber unsere trockenen laufen barfuß
herum
aber es ist schweinekalt würde
wir sind unterwegs in der stadt lucca
hat schuhe und alles gefunden ich nicht
wir sind ziemlich fertig aber es war ein
cooler tag hier die eindrücke sind mega
heiß also wenn ihr auch mal drauf habt
schickt man den link in der beschreibung
ich weiß nicht wie viel ich gefehlt habe
heute auf jeden fall was kommt ja so
noch ein bisschen an steht aber es ist
auf jeden fall cool tag gewesen
und habt ihr aufgefallen klar weil es
mit martin sonst
statt
paperback belasten
besser gesagt